عقود من الافلات من العقاب في انتهاكات
ممنهجه لحقوق الانسان اعطت اسرائيل جراه
في تكرار وتكثيف جرائمها في
فلسطين اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم محكمه العدل الدوليه
تعقد اولى جلساتها بشان الدعوه التي
رفعتها جنوب افريقيا على اسرائيل ووفد
يقول ان نيه ارتكاب الاباده الجماعيه
متوفره على اعلى المستويات السياسيه
والعسكريه في حين ندد اسرائيل بانعقاد
الجلسه وقالت انها شهدت عرض افتراءات لا
اساس لها من
الصحه وتجدون المزيد من اخبار حرب غزه في
رابط بالتعليق الاول ايران تعتقل 35 شخصا
قالت انهم على صله بالانفجار المزدوج الذي
وقع في مدينه كرمان وادى الى مقتل اكثر من
100 شخص وجرح العشرات السلطات قالت انها
حددت حتى الان هويه احد الانتحاريين وهو
مواطن من تاجيكستان دخل ايران بشكل غير
قانوني رئيس اذربيجان يعلن عن سلام وشيك
مع ارمينيا ويستبعد قيام حرب جديده على
خلفيه التوتر بين البلدين بشان اقليم
ناغورني كارباخ عياف اتهم فرنسا بتدريب
وتسليح ريفان وقال ان هذه المحاولات تهدف
الى ابقاء بلاده تحت ضغط
مستمر اللجنه المحليه المنظمه لكاس اسيا
المقامه في قطر تقول ان مبيعات تذاكر
البطوله قاربت 900 الف تذكره حتى الان
وتؤكد ان عمليه التبرع بريع التذاكر سيخصص
لدعم اهالي قطاع غزه الذين يعانون من
اعتداء اسرائيلي مستمر الى
اللقاء